[Music]
tonight we're happy to introduce a new
local sponsor to the program yeah and
actually we have their latest dad we're
going to show it to now let's take a
look hey there mr. cat
you look so fuzzy and and dammit
Tonia what's wrong I just I don't know
what to sing to the cat Oh
do you have cat song writer's block then
you need songs you can sing to your cat
singing to your cat is an important part
of all of our daily lives and important
studies show that singing to cats is
good so don't so don't so don't let cat
song writer's block get you down get
songs you can sing to your cat
you'll get songs like Feeny Feeny you're
the best even though you have stuffing
for brains American kitty dance and a
banana it's the cat you're the cat the
cat you're the cat I got a kiddie pool
mustache and I'm going to the ball
tonight
feed you in the world more important
than anyone else
hey it's mr. black and whites
you're like a furry Oreo but much more
delicious YUM
just kidding I wouldn't eat you it
wouldn't taste good too much blood too
much and many me out anymore act now and
you'll get this bonus CD half a song you
can sing to your dog
you're the greatest dog in the plus you
get a free your cat won't look at it
ball it's a ball your cat is guaranteed
not to look at
just put your wallet in an envelope and
send it to Tom's you can send to your
cat care of behind the trashcan in front
of subway sandwiches in the city you
live in and then a zip code who's mr.
fuzzy was he
[Applause]
no please please that was too stupid all
right
let's agree on that